what if I told you the reality you know
is one of many dr. strange represents an
entirely new aspect to the cinematic
universe just like in the comics dr.
strange deals with parallel dimensions
deals with the multiverse the comics are
very very out there and we've pushed it
with how we film this for movies like
this IMAX is more immersive every set
piece is an attempt to give audiences
visuals and sequences in ways that we
haven't seen them done before open your
eye
Steve Ditko is one of the greatest
Marvel artists in history and that we're
now able to take what he put in the
mid-60s
these trippy comic panels and comic
covers and we now have the technology to
put that into big three-dimensional
space on a movie screen is amazing and
we're not pulling back have a good trip
mr. strange
hey youtubers is Charlie new Doctor
Strange footage just teasing a little
bit of ant-man quantum realm crossover
there's also some wasp news for Avengers
so let's break it down the cool thing
about this you know in addition to Kevin
Feige talking more about Marvel's
multiverse parallel dimensions is the
idea of universes within which is like
the name of the spot that they released
so it reminds you of the Microverse the
quantum realm from ant-man which they
talked a little bit about when the
ant-man movie came out Kevin Feige was
teasing a little bit of Doctor Strange
stuff but we don't really see what that
looks like until now so as he's crashing
through different realms here 2001 Space
Odyssey style we'll talk about that in a
second it looks just like when ant-man
is traveling through the quantum realm
so as the way Marvel tells stories
evolves visually and like contextually
like as we learn more about parallel
dimensions the quantum realm and we get
to ant-man in the wasp that sequel movie
we'll learn more about what's going on
with some of these places but this is
really just like the soft introduction
to that like the ancient one is just
showing dr. strange how crazy things can
get enjoy your journey if she just like
kicks him off on his way but 2001 Space
Odyssey you guys probably recognize that
visual sequence unlike all the colors
bleed together that's kind of what
they're going for the movie like Doctor
Strange the movie takes inspiration from
a lot of different places you have some
Harry Potter with some of the magical
comedy like the cloak of levitation that
won't totally listen to what you want it
to do their fighting style very martial
arts oriented influenced by classic Hong
Kong action films so even if you decide
to roll the dice and take a bunch of
drugs when you go see this movie it's
not going to look anything like any
other Marvel movie you've seen before
which i think is the idea with phase 3
and phase 4 especially in phase 4 like
we're still in the thick of classic
Avengers from phase 1 so even though the
visual style of their movies will evolve
a little bit you're still thinking about
what was happening during phase 1 like
Robert Downey jr. is always going to
look like Robert Downey jr. Thor is
always going to be Thor it's when they
introduce these new characters that they
can like really do something that looks
different but ant-man in the wasp so
there's some pretty big news about the
wasp Evangeline Lilly revealed that
there
not going to include her in Avengers
infinity war ii like the fourth Avengers
film whatever ends up being titled like
New Avengers our all-new all-different
Avengers or whatever it is she said that
that's the first movie she will be in in
full wasp attire because Ant Man in the
wasp is one of the first movies after
the first Avengers infinity war film and
they want to hold off on the wasp reveal
for the ant-man in the wasp movie so
it'd be like them saying they don't want
to introduce like a she-hulk
character until another Hulk film like
they don't want to give that big reveal
away to somebody else's film although
technically Avengers is everyone's film
but you get the idea they don't want to
bury the wasp reveal with a whole bunch
of other stuff that's going on like you
have Captain Marvel stuff that's going
on like you don't want to overshadow so
I'm all in favor of them trying to not
crowd Avengers infinity where there's
just like so many characters in that
already so getting back to ant-man
quantum realm stuff obviously they tease
the quantum realm in the first movie dr.
strange is overlapping with that a
little bit let me know in the comments
do you think that ant-man and the wasp
will travel back to the quantum realm
and we'll learn more about what happened
to Janet Van Dyne after she disappeared
in the grand scheme of things she could
still be alive just because time
operates differently at that level but
the thing is is that a lot of people
heard Sharon Stone's say that she had a
we as in tiny role in a Marvel film
people were like oh man
maybe she's going to be Janet Van Dyne
so they could do like a Basic Instinct
reunion with Michael Douglas in the next
ant-man movie but since then it's come
out that she's actually in the guardians
of the galaxy sequel in just like a
really small role not literally small
just like very brief but that's okay
they could still do Janet Van Dyne in
the next ant-man movie I feel like if
they go back to the quantum realm you
have to address what happened to her
because there is a universes exist that
like you talk about the Microverse the
quantum realm the Microverse is a
slightly different thing but you get the
idea like beings that live at the
quantum state but yet hi dr. strange is
almost here it's literally less than a
month away and for a lot of you that
live outside the United States you'll
actually get to see it at the end of
October most of us in the United States
have to wait to like that
week in November but we're all pretty
much seeing it within about seven days
of each other so get hype and if you
guys haven't been reading it Doctor
Strange just kind of rebooted its comic
book is doing some really interesting
stuff it's pretty trippy but you don't
have to read the comics to understand
what's going on in the movie if you've
seen the other Marvel movies then you'll
be able to pick up on a lot of the
Easter eggs there'll be a lot of
internal Easter eggs but if you are a
huge Steve Ditko classic Doctor Strange
fan it's all in there like you'll see
like Kevin Feige talks about Steve Ditko
most amazing person ever you'll see all
that stuff in there so congratulations
to this week's Marvel giveaway winner
Bryan Purcell you and a $20 Amazon gift
card please private message me on the
back end of my channel so I can get your
contact details there is a new round of
the Marvel giveaway too just because so
much Marvel DC stuff is happening I'm
going to keep all of those giveaways
going week to week so all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video tonight Superman
debuts on Supergirl episode 1 I'll post
my video after it airs so when I post
that I'll explain a little bit about
what's going on with the DC stuff this
week so I try to keep the Marvel stuff
in Marvel videos DC stuff in DC videos
just to keep it organized where you guys
wait for that to post you can click here
for my Iron Fist trailer breakdown and
you can click here for my Superman
Supergirl trailer breakdown thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight